[Music]
how did you enjoy that extra hour of
sleep today this morning Mark the end of
daylight saving time and though we added
that hour we're now losing an hour of
daylight for some it can be a hard
adjustment especially for the first week
that follows Victoria Saha has tips for
the transition
turn back your clocks if you haven't
done so because daylight savings ended
at 2 a.m Sunday and as many of you might
have woken up feeling well rested
because of that extra hour of sleep
experts say the time change could come
with some dangers we know that there is
a higher risk of heart disease higher
risk of Strokes higher risk of accidents
higher risk of medical errors even if
it's an hour difference it's still a
sudden change to our circadian rhythm Dr
Karana says the first week will be the
hardest as we adjust to less daylight at
Nevada mental health we see a fair
number of patients who do struggle with
this seasonal component of depression he
says the best way to combat it is
stepping Outdoors the best way to adjust
that is be outside be in the sun let
your body get reset follow your sleep
follow your routine maintain sleep
hygiene and for parents even if your
kids got an extra hour of sleep this
morning do Dr khurana says that doesn't
mean they can stay up an extra hour
tonight make sure to stick to their
normal bedtime routine so their body can
adjust Victoria Saha 8 news now a
reminder cell phones and other smart
devices may have switched those times
automatically but you probably still
have to manually change the time and
maybe your car or on other appliances we
go back to Daylight Saving Time in March
where we set those clocks forward an
hour